he's chris sims who joins us on the
program on loan from pro football talk
live um where do you want to start today
chris
well i mean that's why they pay you the
big bucks
but i guess i guess but i guess the big
thing to talk about would be last
night's game right i mean what are you
taking away
from that game do you start to go oh are
the raiders
a team to watch out for here or are we
still not sure
about the saints through two weeks and
things don't look smooth and they're not
playing their best football
i tend to be on that a little bit more
right now where i'm a little more
concerned with the way the saints look
to start and it feels like the
national conversation has to do with
drew brees like people were
alarmed that drew brees all of a sudden
looks
average yeah 41. yeah
and i don't know if it's okay you're
that age like
three years ago was his arm any stronger
like i i don't know
it just feels like everybody got a
chance to see him
he might get younger next week if he
throws three touchdowns though chris so
you know how this works it's week to
week here but
is drew brees a concern for you
he definitely is there's no doubt about
it that he is a concern for me with the
saints well i mean first off
you you see the game last night you know
the first two series
it's great execution things are going
good sean payton's got his early plays
he wants to go doing the game plan
but then after that raiders make
adjustments whatever the game settles in
and you see that it offense is hard for
the saints
it's it's always got to be a 12 play 80
yard drive there's never a big play in
the pass game to take pressure off the
offense and
yeah i think between the last two weeks
with everybody wanting to tune in to see
breeze and brady
and now it's monday night football the
new las vegas raider stadium and
everything like that
i think people are you know seeing
something that i know you and i talked
about a little last year where it was
concerning
and here it is kind of rearing its ugly
head once again and no michael thomas
i understand that he's a big part of the
offense and he really is great for drew
brees because
he works the middle of the field and all
those short intermediate routes so not
having them hurt their offense
but nonetheless we're seeing too many
errant throws balls that die
out and don't get to the target and
things like that that i think are a
little more concerning than in the past
are the raiders all in on derrick carr
cause john gruden keeps reminding us how
much he loves derek carr but boy
you you love him so much you entertained
tom brady you thought about trading up
to get kyler murray you brought in rice
mariota
i don't know if that's how you show love
to your quarterback
no no i'm not sure they're all in on him
yet either i don't i don't think they
are i think this is a proven year for
derek carr
where he's gonna have to continue to
play the way he's played these first two
weeks
and probably then some you know even
then early on in the game you saw brian
greasy on monday night football kind of
talking about oh
i wish derek carr would have pushed the
ball down the field there's still
moments where he lacks aggressiveness
if he can bring that to his game you can
see he's very smart he's unbelievably
accurate i mean
balls on the money all night long
letting receivers run after the catch
but
no i don't think they're sold on it you
explained it they've been flirting with
people
and sending out mixed messages for the
last few years and i think he's going to
have to have a real good year
to continue to be that guy there in in
las vegas
what do you do if you're the chargers
after that performance
by justin herbert where your head coach
says
hey we lost the game i you didn't lose
it because of justin herbert
no you did not and i you know i i am one
that tends to go let's go with justin
herbert i mean you want to play
run the football ball control play
through your defense style of football
well he proved to us he can do that now
i know he threw the interception you
know 17-9 and made the rookie mistake
but the other thing i would argue too is
he made plays
that tyrod taylor is just not going to
make i'm sorry there's no other way to
say that i mean herbert has
i think as you saw a little bit some
eye-popping talent some throws and runs
where you go whoa
that's a little different right there
and to me with the way they want to play
it he seems like a very smart kid he
certainly didn't blink in the pressure
of the big lights or anything like that
and you got the carolina panthers this
week i i think the time would be right
now for
to throw herbert in there and start the
future do you think the patriots style
with cam newton is sustainable
i do i think that you know cam is going
to have to continue to be
careful and he is usually running the
football
except when he gets into those third and
one
fourth and one type runs where we saw
and those have really been the only
big collisions he's had running the
football to this point but
i think two things they're they're gonna
take those quarterback runs when the
defensive schemes present itself like it
did in miami
two weeks ago with okay it was there to
be had hey cam you keep the ball
but the big thing is i think he's gonna
give them great confidence to continue
to be able to go hey
even if he can't run the ball we saw man
his ability to stay in the pocket make
the right throw make some game-changing
type throws
it is very real and that will give them
some leeway too to maybe go oh when in
doubt all right this guy knows our
offense he knows where to go with the
ball and he throws it you know the
correct ball too
um i'm very excited by what i've seen
out of that offense and cam newton in
new england at this point i think it's
just at the beginning phases of where it
can grow
but would you sign him up i know they
got him for a bargain
but is there a point where the patriots
go
maybe we've seen enough that we need and
and what's cam going to cost you
i that that's going to be the big
question and and i think this
is both of them kind of evaluating each
other as we go along but you're right i
mean
hey if cam continues to play the way
he's playing right now
he's gonna go um i want 30 plus million
dollars next year
to play quarterback and i don't know
where the new england patriots go if
he continues to play the way he's
playing right now they're going to go
okay well you deserve it because you
were the man this year
you know again we talked about no
weapons on the patriots offense all last
year and all of a sudden we have weapons
all of a sudden nothing's really changed
except the guy at quarterback and i'm
not trying to take a knock at brady or
anything like that
i'm just saying this guy still has
specialness to his game and his
leadership
and how the pressure he puts on a
defense because of his
his vast skill set and i expect it to be
a good year for him from what i've seen
here and i think he will be the
quarterback here for the next few years
in new england
yeah because he's he's going to be a big
ticket item if he's playing this
well and he's only what 31 so he
still could get maybe that three or four
year deal we're talking to chris sims
pro football
talk co-host nbc football night america
analyst as well
i'm surprised that both sides of the
onside kick in dallas
didn't understand the rule for the
onside kick
chris i i i'm amazed i mean
atlanta i don't know what they were
doing it's a shocking that they sat
there and once you saw the ball get to
the seven or eight yard mark
to just continue to sit there and watch
it and when you see the balls rolling in
that direction yeah obviously details
were not talked about there
and they need to be more thorough and to
your point
what i heard you open up the segment
with and this is what i argue a lot with
even like when you do the nfl
top 100. you got guys in the nfl
who they just play football and i'm not
trying but they're not going home and
watching sunday night football or monday
night football or keeping up what's
going on in the league
they go to practice they do what the
coach says they like
playing the game but they're not all in
and as you can see some guys don't
understand what the hell is going on out
there at times yeah but you're on the
kickoff team
uh it's amazing i have no answer for you
all i can say is that
that game was a debacle with some of the
coaching decisions i mean
to go for two up 26 to seven in the
second quarter
i didn't know coaches could tell the
future now and they know how it's going
to unfold oh look that point kind of
came in handy losing by
one you know the onside kick mike
mccarthy going for two
down nine what i mean i i don't know it
that's
just analytics and stuff like this is
driving me crazy right now
you know this kind of mask though what
was going on in dallas i mean they they
got to win a miracle win here
and now you go to seattle this weekend
and
that seattle team seems to know what
they're doing and now they're
you know letting russ cook a little bit
here yeah um
what do you expect to happen dallas
seattle
i think dallas i i think we could see a
shootout in this game really
i do because i'm a little like dallas's
defense is not exactly uh you know
blown me away through the first two
weeks either i mean we saw last week and
the rams they kind of moved the ball up
and down the field on them
and seattle's this is the best russ's
look
it's the best weapons he's ever had
around him and brian schottenheimer the
offensive coordinator
got to give him a lot of credit for
changing his
you know persona run first to realize
wait the strength of our team is through
the pass game
he's really grown the offense i
questioned whether how much
he can be creative in the past game and
things like that been really impressed
with what i saw through two weeks
and their defense you know it it tells
me in seattle's gonna play this way the
whole year dan
because the defense is playing
aggressive too it's not
ben don't break it's a little bit like
hey
we're gonna blitz jamal adams and we're
gonna make a strip sack fumble or get
the ball back
or we might give a big play up and you
score but oh well russell be back on the
field and we're comfortable with getting
in a shootout
and i think they're going to be very
comfortable with what we've seen the
first two weeks all year long
i went back and watched carson wentz in
the first half and
i i never played the position but
i know footwork and his footwork looks
terrible for a guy who we thought was
established
and a franchise quarterback but like
what happened to carson wentz here
and i haven't watched the film in that
game it's something that's on my docket
here
this morning that i'm going to go back
and watch but it is concerning
you know he's first off needs a little
bit of the governor of like man that's
too tight of a window or
go down there there's nine guys on you
just take the sack don't try to flip a
ball to somebody and do things like that
i do think he's a little aggressive
tries to make too much happen at times
offensively they're struggling to find
their way we know they got the offensive
line injuries
and yeah at times he just
doesn't have the proper mechanics throw
in the football or he'll just
lock his legs in the ground and try to
throw the ball in an awkward position
but it's not been good he cost him the
first game with some of the play calling
and
and last week was not a good look either
and and sean mcveigh had a lot to do
with that too with what he's doing on
the offensive side too
i don't know what your reaction was to
trent dilfer trent dilfer said that the
packers
drafted jordan love to basically
you know get aaron rodgers upset
like do you think that they would
actually like it
are they reverting to something that
sounds as desperate as that
to get aaron rodgers motivated damn
i mean i i i that that would be some zen
master stuff right there
to trade up in the first round just to
do that i mean
they could have just called me the
packers and i would have trashed aaron
rodgers maybe we all
just joined in and we could have pissed
him off and got him to go again you know
what i mean
uh so it certainly has ignited him
and you know there's two things that
jumped out to me about their offense
through the first two weeks
they're much more aggressive with
downfield pass plays and
calling those plays and rogers who i
think was scarred
from years of a very average offense
around him schematically to where
he didn't want to force the ball into a
tight window with the first read he
might hold it and dance around and they
make roger's magic happen
last year i saw a few of those times
where he did that and i went oh no the
first guy is open you got to throw it to
him i remember he got that little spat
with matt lefleur like in week two or
week three and that's what it was about
this year
man dan he's probably in the position
true to form the first guy
if he's open by three inches he throws
that ball in there and throws a strike
and i think it's helped their offense in
the rhythm of their offense a lot
well they also have a great running back
too so that's yes they do
certainly no doubt we brought this
question up yesterday we do this all the
time
paulie somehow loves to shoehorn julian
edelman
into a conversation that has to do with
the hall of fame whose career
i can i can give you julio jones's
career or julian edelman
oh yeah i'm still gonna take julio jones
i'm gonna take julio jones even though
you don't have the ring and that does
stink
in those playoff moments but julio jones
will go down as one of the greatest
receivers
ever julian edelman to me is just
a really good receiver that was a
big piece for a great football yes
paulie yes
chris i can't believe this your dad is
the perfect example phil sims has a
career
he might not be first ballot hall of
fame but phil sims has a ring
and as part of two rings and i would
want that as much as
maybe even a dan marino career rings and
well i
i i get it would you rather have your
dad's career or dan mourinho's career
oh man i i'd probably still go with dan
marino's career i think i
would you know those rings are cool but
damn all the money dan made and the hall
of fame and the isotoner
i think my dad would trade one of those
rings of dan marino for some of his
money
would your dad take dan moreno's career
over him
he might he might i know he made this
comment one time where he went
uh we were talking about this and people
he's like oh
i think it's all a little overrated dan
marino's one of the greatest
quarterbacks of all time and he sat back
for a second and we all sat there and
watched him and he went
and i mean damn i don't know
crap he can have my race maybe i'll take
his money
so it's not that crazy good to talk to
you chris
hope you're welcome thanks for joining
us as always all right be good buddy
i'll talk to you guys see you that's
chris sims pro football talk co-host and
nbc football night america
analyst